some good weather and some good chili
dogs right some good chili dogs
yeah something that actually tasted
really really good today we're
celebrating chili dogs rocky is at a
spot where
their rendition of the classic chili dog
is one of their most popular items hey
what's going on rocky
hey lindsay okay so we are at dirt dog
the famous dirt dog there's two
locations here in vegas one
on the strip and then one here on
rainbow right correct yes
okay you're the general manager here so
it's national chili dog day
it is and thank you so much for coming
in of course this is my first time i got
my wings if you can see the cool wings
on the back yes um
we have to ask you a couple questions
yeah we got a quiz you're the you know
queen of hot dogs at this point
all right one what month is national hot
dog month
that was july it is okay two
what state did chile originate in this
is the hard one
let me think for a little bit uh hit um
chili con carne where did that originate
from texas yes awesome specifically san
antonio
okay okay let's get into it okay what
are the chili items on your menu
all right so we do have these two items
right here so we have our
main one which is the most popular one
is our chili dog
and then we do have the chili fries so
usually uh when customers come in
um they usually um order the the hotdog
sometimes with the onions grilled
but we originally serve it with raw
onions and cilantro okay that's very
classic
definitely and i know that you know
everybody makes chili different right
there's no right way
but you guys have a very unique recipe
into it so
um i see it unique because ours is a
chorizo chili
so other places they do not have
um they have maybe beans on it but we
don't put any beans it has the
chorizo which i think it gives it like a
distinct flavor to it
yeah and that creates um the whole uh
chili dog
also with the fries that you see on the
side oh my gosh so
i think you should give it a try okay oh
my god how do i even do what's the right
way to eat a dirt so
you could eat it with your hair i know
you say if you're feeling dirty come on
in right definitely so then i might as
well just go ahead
just go right all right the classic
what's it called on the menu it's a
chili dog
so what do you think oh my gosh that is
delicious okay coming up
we're going to talk about the rest of
these items and their very impressive
menu
oh my god it just there's so much flavor
god he likes it okay how did they come
up with that name rocky
that's crazy
[Laughter]
what is it called on the menu yeah chili
dog
okay all right thank you rocky we'll
check back in with you later on in the
show